do you think that teaching screenwriting
or these books or whatever is is selling
false hope so that's one one criticism
of some of what we've seen it and I
don't see why that would be selling
false hope if that's something someone
enjoys and they love the process of
creating okay I love this because I
believe that my job as a writing teacher
is to facilitate writers in finding the
story that lives within them and stay
out of the result in other words when
you get into the result that's when you
get tripped up that's when you don't
really write from your heart that's when
you don't write something that's
actually gonna be meaningful to other
people and so that's it I always think
of writing as a two-tiered process the
first tier is you have to write it for
yourself and then the second tier is
once you've written it for yourself once
you've written that stuff that you think
oh my god I can't show this to anybody
it's way too personal even if it's
fiction especially if it's fiction it's
there's there's gonna be you've gotta
have some skin in the game you got to be
invested in this thing that you're
writing you've got a let go of this idea
that is it going to sell we can't you
know I remember when I wrote my first
novel I I woke up one day and I was like
I've been writing for a long time I was
making a living as a stand-up comic but
I've been writing for a long time and I
hadn't sold anything and I thought well
you know let me do the math here clearly
I must be a mediocre writer if I've been
writing for this long and haven't sold
anything so what I'm gonna do is I'm
going to stop writing for the
marketplace whatever that is and I'm
gonna write something for myself I'm
gonna write something that really means
something to me and I wrote a story that
and I were really quick that I wrote a
novel called Diamond Dogs and got it
through through through this this lawyer
friend of mine got it to an agent she
auctioned it a week later for a
ridiculous amount of money and then it
became a best-seller and it
what a bunch of awards and and it was it
was the first time I realized that I
don't know anything and when I try and
you notice how I say my idea my story's
never the whole story my idea of of
who's gonna like this or who's gonna
like that is I I don't I can't control
the result we none of us have any
control over the result but what we do
have control over is understanding that
we're all unique we all have something
valuable to say and I really believe
that as a writer and as a writing
teacher and so I want to help writers I
can't predict who's some of my students
have gone on to become best-selling
authors showrunners a were a list
screenwriters I didn't know who they
were gonna be but the the ingredient
that I think is is most valuable isn't
talent whatever that is it's a
willingness to learn
it's a humility it's a willingness to be
curious about the story that lives
within you you know it's it's it's the
humility to put it on the page while
staying out of the result that's really
hard for people that's that's the really
challenging that's a really challenging
test that's being a writer is a marathon
it's not a sprint and if you expect
immediate results you know you're you
might not stay in the game long enough
to experience the fruits of your labor
you